the recent rains seem light here in the
Las Vegas Valley but about 45 minutes
outside here it is a different story
Moapa Valley historically floods during
rain and people living there want more
work done to prevent that but as Ryan
mathie shows us it's become a battle
between County and community
[Music]
Arturo via viescas can't get to his
house by car anymore so all the
the roads like the rivers flooding in
the Moapa Valley left the road up to his
home split down the middle you're saying
the water was up to here yes in this
area across I-15 the town of Overton was
spared this storm but capalapa Family
Resource Center at the bottom of three
roads still recovering from September
flooding according to director Penny
vallone if we're trying to care of
cleaning up
you know servicing for food stamps or
snap Medicaid or even you know our food
bank that we have look at all this water
it's a common sight for these rural
communities about an hour outside Las
Vegas near the Utah border rain turns
these lower elevations along the muddy
river into small lakes
people here want more flood mitigation
and drain maintenance Clark County
Commissioner Marilyn Kirkpatrick tells
us some work has already been done but
other work to prevent this would take
new development and Zoning changes which
come with new infrastructure she says
people here reject these developments
when they're discussed at Town Advisory
board meetings so until County and
Community come to an agreement these
communities continue to fear the next
storm coming I'm getting worried for us
we can only do so much we're kind of
sitting ducks